I talked about my moment with God where
he told me you're going to do something
special someday someday and I don't know
what it is it may still be to come who
knows but I know that putting me in the
center of all of this with my fighting
spirit I believe that God is truly in
control at this moment and we win I
believe we win at the end of the day
he plays mild Applause for that and part
of it is the her she didn't have big
crowds she's here for a reason right
he doesn't make accidents he doesn't he
doesn't
accidentally places where we are we are
here for a reason just the same as our
founding fathers at that pivotal moment
where place where they were in 1776 Sam
Adams Patrick Henry and what we're
facing right now is no different yeah in
the same way that God placed Paul Revere
in a position to be one of the founders
he placed Carrie Lake in a position to I
guess lose the governorship of Arizona